got to hit the gritty
boys oh oh oh that's a good mod you want
to see a new moon Mark always mark this
is called Ren what you really want to do
is follow the lights
okayo wo what is what wait w w I'm going
to open the present you guys ready
y that's a problem that's not my
favorite thing that's ever happened Bob
was that you playing with your
soundboard Mark you watch that I'm going
to uh probably you know me Jesus Christ
someone was talking while Bob was
talking Bob was talking while Bob was
talking what do you mean what do you
mean look at I'm looking at it oh she
walked away what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean oh oh look look at
all the friends Wade has those aren't us
I left some more stuff on the stairs I
might need another hand to grab it all
should we all go back should should
let's do that oh wow you guys finally
made it oh wait wait wait a minute that
that wait wait wait wait wait uh uh bad
bad bad we woo we woo oh my God why are
you here ship weoo ship we woo I have a
shovel I have a
shovel thank you thank you get away from
it take
off take off damn it close the door
through the close the door why isn't the
dooring save me save me save me SA
ah why was the door not
closing I don't know man why is Bob
gone it dragged him off with
it why was the door not closing I don't
know wait is it the red button or the
green button that closes the door red
closes you guys are
idiots I saved your life like five times
you couldn't hit him with the shot I was
trying to close the door but no one told
me which button closes it I was maybe
push the other one if it doesn't work I
was in a tizzy I I you couldn't have
just turn you couldn't have just
shuffled it one time I was I I was
swinging but I was kind of a far away
and I don't know it was so much was
happening it's okay it's okay we did we
go to the company did we go to the
company day one to the company all right
all is good we love the company we love
the company we we love I don't know if
it all is good we love the comp you know
whenever I told you guys to come back
and get Loop there were two of those
guys there was an enemy Mark hasn't seen
yet and there was a little girl all
coming after me that's really there
can't be enemies here can there no not
as far as I know okay well I just now I
don't trust
anything well I think we got a good haul
we got so much crap um not high I think
we did I think you're right I think I
think we're good but we're okay these
Ryan and Reynolds got to be worth a
pretty penny sell sell sell it won't let
me sell it oh your then full up back up
I'll all right we
good wait is it still open it looks open
oh my God work is invaluable to the
company fine calm
down not like your friends SS for me oh
scaps for us you going to give us some
money you better yeah you better back
away like man that door looks real open
let me put my eyes in
there all right oh my
flashlight guys we got 1121 Buck arinos
that's a good hole that's a great hole
so do we like have to pay
renter oh you have to pay every time
somebody die ooh what I like that very
much what well it's not flush to the
wall yeah can you scoot can you scoot
that over wa I never learned how to do
that uh just press B on it and you can
move it wherever it's green oh got it
here Mark I'll I'll fix it for you I'll
fix it for you yeah thank you my walkie
in the corner is gone where did it go oh
I took that I thought that was mine cuz
I died let me die I mean I went just
start ship Mark was failing to try to
close the door we were trying to help
well yeah I was trying to help the fact
that they chased us all the way back
here and I don't know if you guys peeped
inside the building at all but it was
not much better inside than it was
outside surprisingly hard to accomplish
Mark but you're look look up at the top
oh no oh for God's sake hang on hang on
wa no no it's good one says like the
directions are good one I guess it's
painted big yellow so we'll know the
difference no I got I got it I got it I
got this i got this okay okay okay I
think that's part of why it's not PL oh
how about that that's medium it's better
that's better that's good it disappears
into the Shadows no one will know that's
good I like that that's good for me yeah
can we move this stupid clothes rack uh
no apparently not Mark can you look up
now look up look look
up good wait can you
just why you got to ruin my hard work
well one I'm me two I found it hilarious
should we get out of here yeah we should
Bob good idea Bob Mark do you want to be
the first one to Rod the
[Music]
lightning man
oh okay ignore the thes are unrelated I
would be honored to ride your lightning
all right Mark volunteers to Ride the
Lightning where we going wi what is we
got to wait for the quota to up and then
I'll look hey overtime
bonus oh wow what is it that how does
that
calculate numbers all hey Mark you want
to see another new place not at all
great but we're going to a place called
Titan like we love the company the
company the
compy love
the
love the compy yeah okay
okay sorry I wasn't looking down you
don't know where I'm looking you can
watch I love the company yeah okay hey
you know what Mark you want you want the
perfect you want the perfect perspective
Mark yeah what's up here you go yeah
okay I have a let's yes that's for you
bud
thanks oh hey hey what's up my walk in
there all right let's land let's land
this chicken
Co love the comp Company the company a
company hey hey's go get some
[Music]
loot H wait Hazard wait am I rid I'm not
ready to Ride the Lightning what do you
mean oh my god oh Mark are you all right
are you ready to Ride the Lightning I
was not oh man um yeah light do you want
to ride the lightning you want to see
the way in no I'll Ride the Lightning
all right Ride the Lightning all right
radio check oh I guess we're going wait
uh final words would love to have more
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
were you
still were you stuck inside of something
I was in a
staircase oh that's bad lightning guys
that's bad lightning don't ride that you
Dro those
thanks oh yeah by the way it works the
same as the other teleport you lose uh
yeah yeah um okay cool the liting
yeah me baby get get in Mar get in I'm
in oh
[Music]
no
no no not
this
no
[Music]
oh
no oh my God were you stuck again no I
was not I was par I was afraid to move
oh so um this is a modded map this is
not a default map yeah think Bob's okay
he's fine I'm just going to go in the
normal way I don't want to Ride the
Lightning I don't like the lightning
lightning is not for me good old feet
I'll find a shortcut it'll be fine uh I
there's really only two ways up and this
is definitely the shorter one right here
okay all right we're on a rescue mission
operation get loot find Bob all right in
that order yeah for the company of
course for the company for the
company so uh I don't want to pay the
deceased crew fee fire exits right there
like right on this catwalk main entrance
is right here all right good to know see
on
the oh
God
anybody radio
check God I don't remember
this I do remember this
um that's not
right it's not quite as I
remember hey Mark I might be dying very
very
soon uh well think positively pal you'll
get through
[Music]
this
buddy
buddy well it's it's unlikely that both
of them are
dead oh
man just like old times it's
hello okay so if I remember this
correctly that's probably where I just
came from I don't know if I checked the
side
bathroom oh that's bad
sounds that's bad sounds
okay oh
my God what are you okay thought it it
was a Dar
pickles
hello hey bud
hello oh what do you what what what wait
wait wait did you not just see the thing
that was over there how how did you
hey who what what oh wait oh oh
oh
oh oh oh oh
oh oh what
Freddie hi guys how's it going
hello
hello hello oh that's not
good truly terrible truly terrible truly
terrible times truly terrible guys truly
terrible truly
terrible
okay so that's not where it was oh my
god oh I think I just shot my pants what
in the
hell okay yeah downstairs that's a good
idea oh yeah this is where I want to be
oh
[Music]
yeah oh
good if anyone's alive I could use a
Teleport what it's probably gone
[Music]
right oh
go
[Music]
oh I'm gunning it oh my God I'm gunning
it I'm gunning it oh my God I'm gunning
it oh my God oh my God oh my God I'm
gunning
it wait do you have one of these
wait wait you're
[Music]
alive oh no how you can't have a walkie
how do you have a walkie what do you
mean how do I have a walkie I I have a
walkie because I walked
in no you're dead Wade's carrying your
corpse no I'm alive I'm carrying Wade's
corpse
oh why did you assume that that was the
way oh yeah why did youe oh I see yeah
okay yeah you're just going to yeah
okay
oh my God oh my God oh oh what is that
help
help get in here get get
ins hey man hi thanks for carrying me
back I wouldn't leave you
buddy I'm sorry that I had to die like
that in front of you it was uh truly
scarring and now Bob is scarred cuz I
died right right in front of
him all right I see he got your
body you were inside the doorway for me
but I don't know if he's going to pop
out to grab you or not he could no well
I think I'm eating aren't I oh there I
am oh good yeah that's a smart move he
should at least step out on the balcony
to grab the loot that's right oh well
he's not going to it's right there but
yeah he's not going to oh wait uh wait
come here come here come here come here
here come here here here if you don't
touch the body stuff outside oh it's
right there oh it was definitely right
there oh it was right there okay oh the
laziest employee oh honestly that's the
most profitable I did nothing but run oh
the the stuff was right outside the door
did you see the dog and also the girl
making my head explode no I didn't
that's what was going I had like moments
to spare on that one I almost didn't
even get your corpses back okay I
understand I understand yeah he I don't
know how he got to me I don't know how
that was a oneway street he ran past two
things I so I went yeah I went to the
fire exit and then uh I knew I was not
long for this world I was like well I
better at least go find Mark and I got
to you and the moment I got to you yeah
she uh came for me he ran past two
things actually I closed a door when I
knew two things were on the other side
and then the door opened and I was like
I'm and it's Wade and I'm like
what and then his head
[Laughter]
exploded I saw is offensive Mark I
presumed Wade was carrying your dead
body and you know what I am sorry about
that thank you thank you means a lot you
did a good job buddy no that's so nice
uh but also yeah that was a terrible
place it evoked too many terrible
memories I never want to go back
are we I'm so sorry Mark I cut you off
take us right back oh all right okay
Mark you want to ride the lightning no I
do not want to Ride the
Lightning not want to Ride the
Lightning opposite of lightning Mark
there's some lightning to ride I don't
want to ride it there's a there's a Tak
on the floor right here and another
extra flashlight and shovel here need
help carrying
back all right thank
you the snow's kind of loud here you
know what guys I think we have enough
shovels I got to be honest I'm going to
quit buying shovels I think we're we're
pretty shoveled up with all right yeah I
would agree all right see well you know
I'm actually going to take a shovel just
in case we've got so many no our
collection it's okay I'll bring it
back why' you say what's the worst that
could happen why you saying things like
that I heard Wade talking almost the
entire round last time I did not like it
oh is it because of my voice or because
you knew I wasn't there cuz I knew you
were there was one point where it was
all Bob was that you did you ever hear
me at some point or was that yes I was
when I was I heard your
voice there's definitely a mimic so we
should all get our lines out now hey
it's me don't
worry guys I'm over here I found some
can you come come closer come closer oh
guys we should
go that was just you doing that you you
did you just you doing oh God
no oh it's horrible natural it's
horrible it's horrible in
here
yeah you all right Mark you sound a
concern it's fine just guard for life
I'm
fine at least this place looks normal I
found the fire exit it's right over here
I'm making a
jump if I go suddenly quiet after this I
didn't make the jump please check in on
me over here made it Mark Mark Mark are
you there I made it I made it I made it
he's good wait I think Mark
died no I didn't die I'm alive and I'm
fine found a gift wait if you see Mark I
think you should Shuffle him I think
he's a mimic good to know we'll
do you guys think you're real
funny Mark there's a wedding ring right
next to you
there got
it how do I know you're not a a
mimic yeah a mimic do this wait I walked
in here
whoa you walked in here and went left
which is right here you're not hearing
the squashy footy steps no but that
means I'm on the correct side of this
Gap no wait all right I'm going to make
this
jump uh Bob how you doing
status
good outside fire Freddy Freddy Freddy
we got a Freddy I'm going out the fire
exit okay yeah screw that screw
that
b hello can you hear me Bob Mark out the
bad
fire
oh I was trying to tell him to stop but
he just
went oh so Mark is actually dead
now yeah he's he's very
dead I think I have enough I'm going to
start loading out uh to the ship I've
got like more than a load
already
oh hey hey man I'm going to uh I'm going
to take a load come back get another the
load I I hope Mark's okay cuz I think
his heart stopped when
he
fire I didn't even have a chance to warn
him he's just like I'm going out this
fire and
win oh here you know what I'll did he
get eaten then can I not even get his a
there there's nothing
left well there's a red try to go get
his stuff I'm going to go get his walkie
and flashlight Red Dot roaming around
where his body there's a there's a
Bracken in there oh cool I love those
guys that was the reason he ran to the
fire ex was he saw it he saw Freddy BR
Bear yeah oh Mark I should Billy but God
was hilarious watching that
happen what that there a
dog oh my God who how did you get up
here so
fast I R I thought you were behind me
and then the dog was behind me no no I
was ahead of you oh did you hear it
talking as me yeah I think so oh that's
good me well should we just like I have
another
yeah I'm going to just say goodbye to
Mark stuff there's a weeping angel right
inside the door oh cool yeah let's
leave wait there's a dog coming up the
way we just came we should go it's fine
it's
fine
what oh my God where did that come from
where did that it came from inside of me
honest to God I was above I don't know
what happened how do I I I was watching
you in third person and I didn't see it
come up on
you Hey look it's my body wow yeah no
that door was not a door that uh no I I
have never actually experienced one of
those but hasn't gone very well for so
far yeah that uh no one prepped me for
that I was like I saw Freddy Fazbear and
I was like ah yeah I'm just going to not
very well at
all uh it's uh it's I recommend it it's
it's good good times I think I almost
just vomited out my testicles when the
dog got me from inside of my space
that's what happened to me I I don't
understand that was like the biggest
scare I've had in a long time I don't
understand how the dog killed me I don't
understand wait you don't understand
either I was watching Bob in third
person cuz you were jumped down and I
was like oh he's going to get got and
then the dog spawned out of his own
throat like emerged from Bob's wind
pipes how bad was the door scar terrible
that
I I've I did not know that was possible
uh it's a mod it's a mod that's one of
them mods W talking about but I was at
least going to give you a heads up but
you were just so gun ho and you trusted
it so thoroughly I could I did yeah
could I have dodged it if I stepped out
of the way or is it as far as I know no
okay cool it got me once or twice and
then I I've tried to avoid
how do you know we do actually need to
get some stuff today or we're not going
to make yeah we're a little short I
think you can test those doors with a
shovel but if it doesn't I I don't know
what the test is and I think it can go
poorly if you do it all right did you
buy anything W no should we do might
want to buy another walkie and or
flashlight buy one Kill Hunt and kill
yeah that's a bon that's another one of
the mods it's a bonus money objective
all right it'll tell you what to kill
what what's same kill crawler do I have
to do this by myself yeah it's only for
you we I think we can kill it together
when it's hunt and kill okay what's a
crawler it's the big dude with the two
arms and no legs that runs around at
full speed well that doesn't seem good
why do I have to kill that uh it's your
assignment I don't know I didn't give it
to you also it's foggy so it's going to
be hard to see yeah it's really freaking
hard to see what the hell where are we
in the same place we
were yes hey follow our voices that you
can definitely here Mark all right I got
I I got I got I got I got I got it's
fine in theory the loot should be better
because there's a weather condition yeah
and I've got what happens if I don't
complete this objective nothing we
Justus money you bonus okay good all
right well it's not really suck ass Mark
it's fine okay I haven't failed yet the
fact that you have the assignment means
there is a crawler so we know me all
right here we
go yeah
oh it's really holy good good wait
is this the SC is it SCP again yeah it's
SCP oh my God it's
crawler oh yeah that's what that is I'm
separate from you guys why did where did
you guys go no Mark I'm with I'm with
you I think Mark uh I'm going I was wa
actually I lied I lied yeah yeah yeah
uhhuh okay I'm
here all
right oh my God that noise yeah I
know
[Music]
whoa